I've watched these interviews before
it's never been this chaotic
[Music]
hello I'm Charlie puth and I'm here with
BuzzFeed about to answer some questions
while playing with puppies
oh come here yes don't be scared
here do you want to sit on me you're
gonna come right here oh my God
[Music]
the reason why I involve my fans early
on in the music making process is
because I wanted them to Jesus Christ I
wanted them to feel like they wrote
these songs with me kind of like in the
early days of One Direction where their
fans felt like they were responsible for
their success which they were I was
always intrigued as to why there were no
singular songs what the [ __ ] is that
noise
oh it's the puppies come here puppies
I was always I was always wondering why
there were no singular songs where fans
felt like they were there from the very
beginning
you guys were making a special pitch
[Music]
not good enough
that's right the song wasn't good enough
I didn't write hundreds of songs for
this album but I was pretty certain as
to what the 12 songs were going to be
I'm absolutely getting pissed on not yet
but I I know it's common
[Music]
you know like when you capture room tone
I pretended that I was on a film set one
day but I was just me in my studio alone
I recorded the room tone of the room and
it actually captured a pretty uh
interesting sound out the air
conditioner and I layered it with this
hi-hat on this song called Loser which
is track seven and instead of the
hi-hats being stagnant like
I put the air conditioner noise on the
first hi-hat and it was
it's pretty cool hearing it back in my
head now I could have used an open
hi-hat sorry now I'm thinking of the
song
a left and right was originally just me
singing But when I listened back to it I
thought that it called for having like a
different person's perspective on a very
familiar subject which the song is about
and he added a lot of value to it also
the only artist that have ever sent me
perfect vocals or recorded perfect
vocals in front of me are Jungkook Boys
to Men and James Taylor I was he sent me
the vocals all I had to do was just copy
and paste and then we were done
G sharp growls by puppies
[Music]
it was a lot of fun to film was it as
fun as this now but it was fun I really
appreciated him flying in too for it
because he was very jet-lagged what's
going on back don't chew on my stop it
stop it now it's not licorice I've
watched these and stop Jesus I've
watched these interviews before it's
never been this chaotic
Bruce Springsteen Bruce would always
pick up
um Bruce is a quicker texture backer
than
my parents sometimes
I'm I'm most excited to perform Charlie
be quiet live all these songs were kind
of designed to be played in big venues
we're going to be doing that in 2023 and
starting off this year with the intimate
bad news just to get those in one for
one last time
there's a song called reply to this that
I never finished and the internet's an
uproar like why did I never finish it
I'd like to revisit that one day it was
kind of written during a pretty Jesus
pretty transitional time in my career I
get it you're going to be nice and
strong you're going to protect someone's
house one day it's not mine I was
instructed to not adopt any puppies
today even though I want to
I would like to collaborate with Paul
McCartney I love how he still to this
stable incorporate classical music into
his pop music the use of like
chromaticism in his melodic structure I
try and do that too I did that on track
11 on this song called I don't think
that I like her gently nodding to Paul
McCartney do you want to go sorry
ooh tapestry by Carol King no skip album
uh the rock one time and he said he
loved my style
[Music]
I would like to make a cameo on Family
Feud and be the first contestant to not
bring his family on there because no one
would want to go on that show with me in
my family except me just me answering a
bunch of questions
you guys have made me in a silly mood
I would watch 21 Jump Street for the
first time because that was the funniest
movie ever still is if I could hear
My Humps by the Black Eyed Peas like I
did on that beach day in June 2006 for
the first time I would do this
chaos
I'd bring three of these oh that's sad
there's four dogs I'd bring three of
them Sophie's choice I'd bring a CD
player which sounds outdated but like I
still believe that CDs have a higher
sound quality I bring The Marshall
Mathers LP
I'd bring a magical tray that produces
food so I could be nourished and a
never-ending glass of water how about
that
my favorite person that I've
collaborated with is Elton John because
I was so impressed with how he was able
to come up with the chord progression or
the song that we wrote that started off
his album I was just watching him in awe
like Elton John sitting on my Rhodes
piano writing a song yes are you
presenting something to me this is how
I'll hold my future child
thank you BuzzFeed for having me answer
all these questions with these puppies
my new album Charlie is out everywhere
right
I don't tell them about my album my new
album Charlie is out everywhere thanks
for making it the most streamed album in
the world and all of these dogs are
available for adoption at North Shore
Animal League America
[Music]
thank you